hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
those who consume corporate media will
believe the Bolivian army rightfully
overthrew the democratically elected
president of Bolivia the word coup is
not mentioned but this is exactly what
happened the tried-and-tested color
revolution playbook was on display for
anyone paying attention
Bolivia's democracy is in retreat
[Music]
crosstalking bolivia joined by my guess
Pablo no Verratti in London he is a
journalist and documentary filmmaker as
well as co-editor of Albert Rada net an
independent voice on Latin American
politics culture and media in Washington
we have Guadalupe karela Gabriela she is
an associate professor at the shark
school of policy in government at George
Mason University and in Santiago we
cross to Francisco : he is a political
analyst as well as a former UN officer
in Asia and Africa
all right crosstalk rules in effect that
means he can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciate it Pablo let me
go to you first in London I peruse the
American media landscape about the
events that happened in Bolivia the coup
I will use the word but they won't ABC
news Morales resigned simply CBS news
because of Weist widespread protests the
New York Times said because of an
infuriated pop population Fox News said
the people were angry over election
fraud none has been shown to date and
the Miami Herald
welp said that it was they what was
overthrown was a full-blown dictatorship
what's the media coverage in the UK I
bet it's similar very much so I mean I
think the British media and this
includes from the right the so-called
progressive left have been very much
under playing the fact that it's the
coup that was taken place in Bolivia
they talk of a power vacuum they talk of
a resignation but they they don't really
use the word coup and I think this is
not surprising for anyone that's been
looking at the media the British media
is reporting on on Latin America and
especially on the left in Latin America
very much echoes the US media which
again very much echoes there seems to be
a correlation between the degree to
which a country is an official enemy of
the US and the degree to which they will
receive hostile reporting from the US
and UK media what a loop a this is
remarkably similar to what we saw in you
goes in Serbia the ex yugoslavia what we
saw in Ukraine in 2014 and now we're
seeing it in Bolivia this is this color
revolution playbook it
remarkably similar in each one of these
cases here you have these fake NGOs fake
social social groups that are supported
by foreign money training and of course
we have the military that all of Latin
America's military is trained in the
United States so there's so many
different avenues to go after a
government and Bolivia's was open to it
I want to talk about maybe why Laura
Ellis didn't have more firewalls because
they've been doing it to Venezuela for a
while now they've been able to push back
he wasn't go ahead Guadeloupe absolutely
I mean the Democratic car door or fights
for democracy it's just like it's faking
what really is really happening
the Mexican government recognized this I
mean this events as I mean this event is
a coup and definitely we could see how
the elites prepare these to happen but
in reality this is I mean this was not
this was not a resignation from the
president when the military forest is as
a president I mean retire I mean takes
out it's it's support it you know it
doesn't leave any space and Mexico was
very I mean the Mexican president the
Mexican Minister for in a first was very
straightforward this is a coup and so
that's why we are we are assigning
political asylum to the Bolivian
President Evo Morales definitely this is
the result of a so-called color
revolution or a revolution for democracy
that journey to a coup de tat and
there's no question about that and of
course the media is not covering it
correctly
you know Francisco talked about some of
the opposition leaders here I think if
the truth were known about their
ideology and their own worldview people
would be and should be shocked but
nobody's ever told about neo-fascist
ideas and ties to these types of groups
in the past I mean it's all out there if
you want to know but the media won't
report it Francisco talked about that
well fascism is a word that it's not
very much used in that in American
politics I mean I mean people are afraid
I mean even the leftist politician is
afraid of using the word fascism because
you know a 10 of
tends to be a very aggressive definition
of the political moment but basically
what the USA is doing in order to
recover their Germany and premise in the
region is to apply and to use fascist
forces in the region in Brazil they are
doing the Ottoman Persil structurally
speaking the fascist country culturally
I mean this is I'm not saying Caetano
Veloso the singer says that I mean
inside Brazil is it's a very wretched
Society and so now is an example of
animal lineage the same thing I mean
racism was there and and you know there
was a kind of a cover-up sort of say a
very humane cover by morality trying to
say our country has made a very strong
progress in eradicating racism but it
wasn't the case I mean racism oppression
and fascism is present in this school
again more others you know Pablo let's
go back to London I mean if you look at
the stats of the time that Morales was
in power I mean any politician would be
very gratified about that a legacy
dealing with poverty dealing with
illiteracy it's really quite
extraordinary some of the things that he
did now I my viewers know very well I am
a conservative and I am NOT a supporter
of socialism however I am a supporter of
success and I'm a supporter of democracy
and this is what people voted for and
given given the logic that the last
election wasn't fair then why don't you
just let him finish his term ok and
where is the evidence there was fraud
there's none been presented to the
public that I'm aware of
go ahead in London now I think the most
robust exploration of the publicly
available electoral figures by the cep
are the think tank in Washington has
showed that there that's absolutely no
evidence of fraud now I think what Alice
made a mistake inviting the OAS yeah to
Bolivia the OAS has completely
discredited any any type little
legitimacy it had under Luis Almagro has
become an open supporter of the far
right and regime change operations and
most notably
in Venezuela and really this is not
about whether a government does well in
terms of socio-economic indicators
macroeconomic indicators believe it did
very well but it's not really about that
it's about any government that tries to
reassert a degree of sovereignty over
its economic policy over its political
decision-making that tries to
incorporate previously marginalized
sectors into the political process will
come up against the US government's
interests and its local allies this has
happened remember Francisco is in Chile
the birthplace of neoliberal capitalism
where supposedly her it came through by
force and we talked about fascism the
Pinochet dictatorship the degree to
which they even for sophistic policies
torture heute gross human rights
violations this is the model which is
hegemonic it was born in Chile in 1973
it's what people in Chile today are
trying to change and have there's a mass
uprising which is being brutally
repressed of course the OAS and the US
government don't have any qualms with
going along with the right-wing panetta
government yet in Bolivia they will they
will come up with all manner of excuses
to justify the use that's taken place
what a low-paid can you just briefly
tell our viewers what outside forces
were involved in this illegal coup
overthrowing a democratically elected
government go ahead in DC it is very
interesting because a coup like that the
one that we saw cannot take place if you
don't have supporters and definitely the
Organization of American States show and
as we were talking about some
involvement of the international
community led by possibly the United
States and the recognition of the new
self declare president of Bolivia the
receiving support and a recognition that
that elections can take place without
Bolivians electing this person as a
president
the and and the problem is that when you
recognize when when the United States
recognize a government that was not
elected and does not recognize a coup D
etat it you know it justifies the
these this takeover of government so
definitely here there there are players
that are you know very well recognized
that are supporting the elites of of a
country that has over 40 percent of the
total resource of Libya
an important natural resources that we
need to take into account you know
Francisco can you talk about that I mean
you know first of all I think it's
ideological and I think Pablo said it
really well any government that wants to
be to maintain its sovereignty and be
able to determine its destiny is always
a target of these tactics here but there
is an economic angle to this here and
the Bolivian government was beginning to
work closely with countries like China
is this a tipping point where you say
this is that when they make this move
because this was being planned for a
long time they're doing it with
Venezuela they're doing it with
Nicaragua etc it is the timing of this a
coincidence I don't know what I'm just
asking you go ahead well in the US in
the Pentagon there is a red banner in
Venezuela Nicaragua Cuba of course and
the rest of South America red banner
means been threatened by communism I
mean they are paranoid regarding the
rebirth of socialism in the region pink
tide first of all and secondly the
rebirth of autonomy or independence in
the sense I mean I mean the American
foreign policy I started engage them is
a colonial policy towards this region
towards South America I mean definitely
this and and they feel that they have to
take care of the solvent in sphere and
in the trilateral that was their
responsibility
I mean Europe takes care of Africa Japan
takes care of Asia and the USA takes
Atlantic and the Pacific I mean in terms
of the Southern Cone too so and this is
a standard policy in American foreign
policy to control and now they lost that
control the loss to the Nicaragua the
loss and in Cuba Venezuela we lost
Argentina's never okay sure just gonna
jump in here we're gonna go to a short
break and after that short break we'll
continue our discussion on Bolivia's
stay with
welcome back to cross knock where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
to remind you were discussing Bolivia
[Music]
okay let's go back to London with my
question I will date myself
unfortunately but I remember very well I
was a young man very young I've been in
been politically active for a long time
aware of politics but I remember the
military dictatorships okay in South
America and how the US would say give
the people the voice bring democracy to
the region and will bring prosperity etc
etc well now we've had democracy for for
two generations and oh shucks
people vote the wrong way it's amazing
the evolution of the of the Democratic
idea for the Western Hemisphere because
when people vote the wrong way they get
punished go ahead in London absolutely I
mean with that famous quote by Nixon I
believe what Kissinger was when the
Chilean voted in a yen there in 1970 was
which we won't let the irresponsibility
of the Chilean people forget it you know
we won't let that get in the way of what
we want so I think also said that he
would make the economy howl I think was
not to term yeah scream scream he said
and and you know and these are kind of
recipes that the US government has for
enacting regime change we've seen it
with the sanctions in in Venezuela but
just quickly going back to the issue of
lithium I mean I think again to make an
interesting comparison between Chile the
number one current war producer in
lithium where the panera government
effectively hands over lithium
production to Western multinationals
with no value added in Chile in Bolivia
the that Morales government was
attempting to create an industry where
value was added within the country as we
know it said that lithium is a fuel of
the future essential for electric cars
and it was a very complicated process
because of partly because of the type of
scenery there is in Bolivia and Western
companies had been unable to accept the
demands that the Morales government had
put on on coming into partnerships with
with the government and the government
had turned to Chinese companies and now
so I think also this is a very
interesting part of the of this story
which is the degree to which this new
cold war between China
and in the US how things are playing out
in Bolivia that might have affected the
decision to sort of up the ante in terms
of getting rid of Morales by the US
government
well you know we could use the Venezuela
example is that not allowing the
Venezuelan government the fruits of its
own exports I mean you have in the the
US government taking over the Venezuelan
companies and they get the cash not for
the government so it looks like this is
also a tried and tested pattern not
allowing these countries to profit from
their own natural resources amazing go
ahead exactly and again this is this is
this is an effort to pair with the
elites of a country therefore your
question who's behind this economic
interests that are connected to foreign
governments not ever Morales was able to
provide for its people to get the
highest rates of growth in the whole
continent and and a great distribution
of resources for for the people in in
Bolivia and unfortunately now as in the
case of Venezuela Venezuela and Colombia
had a history where the elites were
connected to the military and were
connected to foreign powers so they can
profit from these and and resources
didn't get to the to the people when
left-wing government governments that
were more connected to the people
arrived that generated a lot of unrest
from the elites but now the elites are
able to I mean to pair with the with
foreign governments with foreign
companies and this is going to go back
to what what has been the history of a
country like Bolivia where the resources
don't go to the people you know
Francisco what happens next to the
Bolivian people
I mean Morales was obviously a popular
figure I mean even his detractors cannot
deny that okay even if they want to call
him a dictator he was the people
supported him here what is going to
happen to these people now because up
until the his leaving office from Mexico
there were there were his party there
were officials in his party that were
there houses were being victims of arson
ISM we have
individuals that were tortured publicly
I mean this is some of the mission I've
gleaned from sources like the gray zone
which I encourage our viewers to look at
which we highlighted in this program
before what's gonna happen to the people
is there gonna be a retribution is
there's gonna be some kind of
illustration I mean it was more Alice's
government I mean is it gonna be
completely cleaned out go ahead in
Santiago what I think is a morales quick
departure towards Mexico is because he
was threatened I mean to she was going
to be killed a particular actually never
I mean and they're going to be very hard
I mean the repression against communists
and socialists there and first of all
political tension would grow and the can
to get very fragmented political
speaking and also in territory term
because they would be Indians Indians
people will get marginalized completely
from the benefits I mean it's going to
be a rat's ear against Morales measures
so they go into this mantle socialist
policies whatever socialist policies
we're a function in their in terms of
distribution resources so a thing would
be not chaos but the press which is your
point they press the Western press will
hide and the Bolivian principle has I
think we have to to go for programs and
yours or board press and to get it and
to dig into this iceberg which is not
the iceberg the real good metaphor
because believe it's a very hot country
but this is going to be a thick layer of
fake news of lies and they're going to
be you know what I call a little Jakarta
against leftist in Bolivia
definitely and this is the American
policy particularly from those policies
which trying to recall very quickly a
Germany in the region this is the basic
point in the region
stabilisation States stabilizing any
regime against
you say primacy or ahjummoni and which
is pretty bad because you know if you
read Stephen Ward's you're if John
Mearsheimer
yes sir excellent physical scientists I
mean this crazy or paranoid American
premise II is making harm to Americans
all these regime changes and
machinations do cause population
movements and in the United States will
have itself to blame for that as well
okay the immigration issue is very
complicated but the u.s. does itself no
favors by meddling with its southern
neighbors
Pablo let me go back to you in London we
started out the program talking about
basically whitewashing the events in
Bolivia and to kind of react to what
Francisco had to say I mean if there's a
dirty war committed against the Bolivian
people we're not gonna hear much about
it from the mainstream are we absolutely
not and I think the media needs to the
Western mainstream media have to have a
long look at themselves in the mirror I
mean they haven't learned the lessons of
Iraq when they essentially went along
and obfuscated the reasons for the
growth you know human rights violations
that followed the illegal occupation and
invasion of Iraq with merely with a
million dead if not more and they
continued to systematically distort
misrepresent these processes in Latin
America and then you know we saw it with
the coup against Dilma roussef in Brazil
when there was a kind of reporting that
made it very nebulous around corruption
and now and then they asked themselves
years down the line how did we get to a
situation where we have a fascist in
power so there seems to be they want to
have it both ways where they they kind
of play the game go along with it
obfuscate misreport and then once you
have a far-right leader like Trump in
the US or also Niro in Brazil they say
oh how did we get to this position we
don't know it was terrible you know we
we the liberal center completely against
this so I think the media have you know
a very very big role in in in in the
unfolding of events in how they report
things and I think they need to take
responsibility because what they're
doing now is is really contributing to
cooze
and and and and human rights abuses
you're overly optimistic my friend I
mean considering their behavior with all
these Foreign Wars I mean I could you
know spend a lot of time you know that
Syria comes to mind all right
a shameful role here what a little bait
tell our viewers how they can find out
what's really going on in Bolivia I've
mentioned the gray zone which I
encourage people to go to where else can
they go to besides RT and crosstalk of
course but where else can they go to
learn about these important events I
will tell you something and this is give
me gifts this gives me hope and that has
to do with my country with Mexico
because the government of Mexico has
recognized that there is I mean that
there was a coup in Bolivia and it's
providing support to the government of I
mean to the to the elected president of
Bolivia to ever Morales well he resigned
but he's there and also Mexico and the
Mexican media if they are you know they
are covering what's happening so I see I
see the social media overall I see
Mexican government the Mexican official
communicates but also the social media
blogs people there are conscious of
what's happening you know I I see
Twitter every day I check it very
frequently and people are conscious so
I'm hopeful
many people are not happy with what is
happening in Bolivia and they are
expressing their discontent not in the
mainstream media but people are seeing
that there's something that's not right
happening in our hemisphere okay
Francisco Mexico it's also well I mean
the way they accepted Morales was a very
honorable thing to do and and they
openly express the what really happened
which was what what is actually very
positive I mean because so many other
governments one Francisco I'm gonna give
you the last word in the program one
minute goes to you in Santiago well just
to hold I mean pointed out with what a
loop iam power was saying about the
media I mean the Western media liberal
media has the chance and the opportunity
now to go to the truth the truth and the
facts because they're con
tributing to fascism this will be my
conclusion I mean Western media by not
revealing really what's happening in
Bolivia is contributing to another you
know wave of dictatorships and fascism
in the region which is an era which is
coming pretty close you know well but
what they what I would also maybe the
lot more give myself the last word here
is that what is being diminished the
most is the very idea of participation
in democracy the indigenous people of
Bolivia for the first time under their
ex-president former president now had
that opportunity and that shouldn't be
denied anyone no matter what your skin
color is or your views you should fight
for democracy that's all the time we
have many thanks to my guests in London
Washington and in Santiago and thanks to
our viewers for watching us here at RT
see you next time and remember trust
Huck rules